عندما تأكل الكنغر، يكون لديك ذلك
المذاق، فهو ذو مذاق معدني
أود أن أقول مذاق معدني لأن
لحم الكنغر غني بالحديد مقارنة
باللحم البقري،
لذلك نحن في الأساس بوشمان نستمد
الإلهام من المناطق النائية النمساوية، حيث يجمع
المفهوم بين
المكونات التقليدية وتقنيات طهي
الكنغر  هو في الغالب
طعام السكان الأصليين لأستراليا، وعادةً
لا تجد حيوان الكنغر في معظم
المطاعم في دبي، لذلك
أعتقد أن هناك مطعمين فقط في دبي
يقدمان حيوان الكنغر، ونحن من بينهم وقد حظي
بشعبية كبيرة منذ السنوات الخمس الماضية.
وقد حصلنا على تعليقات إيجابية للغاية
حوله
[موسيقى]
عندما يفكر الناس في الكنغر، فهو
في الأساس حيوان بري، ولم يأتي
من المزرعة، لذا فهو هزيل للغاية
ومستدام للغاية، ولا توجد هرمونات،
ولا توجد مضادات حيوية لأنه تم
اصطياده من البرية للتمليح.  هي العناصر الرئيسية للطبق،
لذلك إذا لم تقم بتتبيل اللحم فلن
تحصل على النتيجة النهائية، لذلك نقوم بتتبيله لمدة
12 ساعة طوال الليل، لذلك نضيف إليه الكثير
من التوابل الحارة فقط لتعزيز
النكهة لأنه  حاد جدًا، لذا فإن
ما نفعله هو أننا نقدم الكثير من البهارات
في هذه التوابل الطبيعية المعززة من
أستراليا، لذلك يترك ورق الغار
قليلًا من السكر البني والملح
والماء وننقعه في المحلول الملحي لمدة 12 ساعة ثم
نضعه على اليمين ثم نضع بعضًا منه
زيت عشبي قليل من الملح وقطعة من الورق
ونشويه على جاسبر،
طبخ الكنغر
مهم جدًا، لا يمكنك الإفراط في طهي
الكنغر في اللحظة التي يصبح فيها أكثر من
متوسط ​​نادر إلى متوسط، وهذا هو المكان الذي
تدمر فيه شريحة لحمك،
لذا  من المهم جدًا طهي
الكنغر في درجة الحرارة المناسبة، ثم
تركه لمدة 10 دقائق وتناوله
فاترًا وليس ساخنًا جدًا لفهم
ملف تعريف الإرادة الحرة للكنغر
[موسيقى]
هو أن لحم البقر الكنغر أصبح
مشهورًا جدًا هذه الأيام.  يحظى
بشعبية كبيرة وكلما قدمنا ​​هذا الطبق
للضيوف فإنهم عادة ما يحبونه
لأنهم لم يجربوا الكنغر
من قبل
[موسيقى]